the Joe Rogan experience well that's one
thing that we did learn from talking to
Jack Dorsey the CEO of Twitter like it's
impossible to manage
there's too many ghosts they're going up
right now by the thousands like if you
could see everyone everyone in America
posting on Twitter right now be like ah
explosion oh my god of ones and zeroes
just busting all over the place and text
just check who do you think like if you
were to grab somebody's phone the most
popular person that gets to tweeted the
most to just motion at it just looked at
it yeah how fast would that go you know
nothing like just that that one account
oh be insane maybe yours boy goes yeah
other people yeah yeah I follow a lot of
other people I just filed whenever
whenever things someone's interesting so
he's got cool pictures a father got yeah
yeah like first yeah let me see yeah so
what else this person's not sure they're
not whack yeah it's really funny as
people get mad at you for certain people
you follow yeah people that you stop
following are Kelly now don't tell me
what to do right that's first of all
first of all don't tell me what to do
what am i doing am i boosting up his
profile yeah he's [ __ ] art Kelly no
doesn't matter if I follow him if I
don't I want to know how crazy he is
yeah that's right - did you see tyrant
Tyron Woodley UFC top welterweight
former champion had a thing on his
Instagram page of him watching are Kelly
getting interviewed where who's he was
who was denying that he knows how to
hog-tie people play this [ __ ] ain't
funny but dog
hagh that's great
he's not using confident tonight I
follow our Kelly for the same reason
yeah that I'd loved Real Talk watch this
video real talk
we played it on the podcast multiple
times Real Talk is one of the greatest
unintentional comedies that's ever been
Real Talk real talk
yes ain't it oh my god what is it it's
an R Kelly song okay we're he's an
argument with girlfriend on the phone
while you are his girlfriend the phone
he's like getting his hair done and [ __ ]
stogies drink it's got like different
outfits on yeah he's still in the
conversation and there's one part where
he goes [ __ ] I wish you would talk
[ __ ] I wish you had burned my
[ __ ] clothes it's about that
listen I absolutely feel for any person
that he's victimized
oh absolutely do you get what you cannot
deny that [ __ ] is [ __ ] flares that
[ __ ] is father so yes there is oh they
just played up
would you try the name trifling-ass is
the best best african-american saying of
all trifle trifling trifling and it's
one that why people cannot use its to I
pronounce it too good they are on that
word that word as much as they own the
n-word right top trifling you can't be
trifling you can't pronounce the G and
trifling yeah you can tackle it yeah
that's why white people are not allowed
to use it
he's out there trifling he's out there
trying again [ __ ] this is a [ __ ]
trifling well here's the thing but gay
guys use trifling
I bet gay guys will pull it out out him
over there with his trifling ass you
know it sounds like a rifle that you
travel with it's a trifle it yeah look
it's a travel rifle they're thinking
abandon those good for long range don't
bring it a trifle with how many people
do you think had to live it up before
Webster had to like answer this question
what is a trifling effort laugh lacking
in significance or solid worth such as a
frivolous trifling be trivial a trifling
gift see chiefly dialectical my god lazy
shiftless in a trifling fellow a
trifling fellow that's most English
thing it got very winding fellow he's a
trifling fellow don't bring over healing
hello yeah that's a word bro so that's a
legit word trifling [ __ ] I was gonna say
something else what did we talk about
right before Kelly Kelly yeah I liked
that point he did an album where it was
a lot of just talking Oh trapped in the
closet yeah yeah I think Aziz had a
whole thing on that like Aziz Ansari did
a bit on it I believe I know you had a
bit yeah about our Kelly it might have
been about trapped in the closet yeah
trap the closet is great but it can't
[ __ ] with real talk
really the jam
[Applause]